.
THEY AREN'T TOO FAR FROM YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IN "FOCUS" NOW GENERAL JACK
KEANE, RETIRED FOUR STAR
GENERAL, FOX NEWS SENIOR
STRATEGIC ANALYST AND CHAIRMAN
AT THE INSTITUTE FOR THE STUDY
OF WAR.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
FIRST OF ALL I WANT YOU TO
REACT TO SOME OF TREY'S
REPORTING THERE ON WHAT WOULD
SEEM TO BE STRATEGY BY PUTIN.
I HAVE BEEN CALLING HIS RUSSIAN
FORCES TERRORISTS BECAUSE THEY
ARE RAINING DOWN TERROR BY
HITTING CIVILIAN TARGETS.
>> THERE ARE TWO WARS TAKING
PLACE.
ONE IN THE SOUTH AND NORTH
BECAUSE THEY ARE SO DIFFERENT.
THE ONE IN THE SOUTH IS FINALLY
BEGINNING TO SUCCEED FROM A
RUSSIAN PERSPECTIVE.
THEY HAVE TAKEN KHERSON, A
CRITICAL CITY IN THE SOUTH.
SURROUNDED MARIUPOL ON THE EAST
AND FORCES ARE APPROACHING
ODESA, THEY HAVE AMPHIBIOUS
LANDING SHIPS AND LIKELY
SENDING FORCES FROM KHERSON IN
THAT DIRECTION AS WELL.
THE PURPOSE AND STRATEGY THE
RUSSIANS ARE USING HERE IS TO
CUT THE UKRAINIANS OFF FROM THE
SEA, WHICH IS WHERE ALL OF
THEIR IMPORTS AND EXPORTS
TRANSIT AND TO BUILD THE LAND
BRIDGE WE'VE TALKED ABOUT MANY
TIMES TO CRIMEA.
THAT WILL LIKELY SUCCEED AND
TAKE SEVERAL MORE DAYS.
THE UNITS THAT ARE DOING THIS
ARE FROM THE SOUTHERN MILITARY
DISTRICT.
MANY ARE BASED OUT OF CRIMEA IN
RUSSIA AND THE FACT THAT THIS
-- THESE UNITS HAVE TRAINED
TOGETHER AND EXERCISED TOGETHER
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS AND I
THINK IT IS A CONTRIBUTOR TO
THE SUCCESS THEY ARE ENJOYING.
IN THE NORTH OPERATIONS ARE
LARGELY STALLED AS OUR
REPORTERS ARE REPORTING.
THEY EVEN TRIED A THIRD AXIS TO
COME INTO KYIV THE LAST COUPLE
OF DAYS AND THAT GOT STALLED AS
WELL.
SO THEY HAVE REAL CHALLENGES
THERE.
A LOT OF THEM ARE LOGISTIC
CHALLENGES BUT THEY ARE ALSO
DEALING WITH THE UNITS
THEMSELVES.
HE BROUGHT UNITS INTO BELARUS
NOW CONDUCTING THE MAIN EFFORT
ON KYIV FROM THE EASTERN PART
OF RUSSIA.
MANY OF THEM ARE HODGE PODGE OF
UNITS NEVER EXERCISED ON LARGE
SCALE TOGETHER BEFORE.
AND YET THEY WERE GIVEN THE
TASK OF THE MAIN EFFORT.
THEY ARE HAVING SIGNIFICANT
LOGISTICS PROBLEMS AS WE HAVE
BEEN ACCURATELY REPORTING.
>> Harris: THAT HAS TO BE A
BENEFIT TO UKRAINE.
EXCUSE ME, I WANT TO GET THIS
IN HERE QUICKLY.
THAT HAS TO BE A BENEFIT TO
UKRAINE FORCES AS THEY WAIT FOR
AMMO TO SHOW UP.
IT HAS TAKEN AWHILE FOR THOSE
MATERIALS TO MOVE TO WHERE THE
FORCES ARE FIGHTING RUSSIA TO
REACH THEM.
QUICKLY LET'S GET TO THIS.
UKRAINE CLAIMS IT HAS KILLED A
TOP RUSSIAN GENERAL.
THE MOST SENIOR FIGURE TO HAVE
BEEN KILLED DURING THE INVASION
SO FAR.
THEY SAY IT REPRESENTS A MAJOR
BLOW TO RUSSIA'S OPERATION.
THE GENERAL JUST ONE OF MORE
THAN 9,000 RUSSIAN TROOPS
UKRAINE SAYS IT HAS KILLED
SINCE THE INVASION BEGAN MORE
THAN A WEEK AGO NOW BY A DAY.
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
DEFICIENCIES IN THE FIGHTING
FORCE.
WHAT DOES THIS DO, TAKING OFF A
TOP GENERAL?
>> WELL, IT'S NOTABLE AND SEE A
LEADER AND THE UNIT SUFFERS AS
A RESULT OF IT.
BUT IT IS NOT THE DEGREE OF
SIGNIFICANCE THAT THEY ARE
CLAIMING.
NO GENERAL ON THAT BATTLEFIELD
OUT THERE THAT'S INDISPENSABLE.
THE FACT IS WHAT'S HAPPENING
WITH THE ORGANIZATIONS ARE THE
ISSUE.
THE REASON WHY THE OPERATION IN
THE NORTH IS STALL UKRAINIAN
RESISTANCE IS A FACTOR,
LOGISTICS THE OTHER ONES.
AS THE VEHICLES WE'VE SEEN
PICTURES OF THEM SIT ON A ROAD
AND THEY ARE SO VULNERABLE.
THE UKRAINIANS ARE ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THAT.
PARTICULARLY AT NIGHT WHEN THEY
ARE ABLE TO OPERATE WITH COVER.
I ALSO BELIEVE THERE IS A LOT
THE UNITED STATES COULD BE
DOING HERE.
WE HAVE COVERT CAPABILITY TO
INTRADIKT THOSE CONVOYS.
THERE IS RISK ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT TO BE SURE.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT THE COST
AND BENEFITS OF IT BUT WE HAVE
DEVELOPED THIS CAPABILITY OVER
A NUMBER OF YEARS AND IT GIVES
US DENYABILITY.
WE CAN ALSO HELP COVERTLY TO
BRING IN SUPPLIES.
RIGHT NOW WHAT'S HAPPENING IS
UKRAINIANS HAVE TO GO TO POLAND
AT THE BORDER TO PICK UP THE
SUPPLIES AND DRIVE THEM BACK.
AT SOME POINT THE RUSSIANS WILL
LIKELY CUT THAT OFF.
WE HAVE TO BE PREPARED TO
CONDUCT AERIAL RESUPPLY AND
PINPOINT AIR DROPS AND LANDING
IN REMOTE AIRFIELDS.
IT'S OUR WILLINGNESS TO ACCEPT
THE RISK.
WILL WE ACCEPT THE RISK IS THE
ISSUE.
>> Harris: I HAVE TO LOT TO
COVER WITH YOU AND WANT TO
PAUSE YOU THERE RESPECTFULLY.
ARE YOU THE PERSON WITH ALL THE
EXPERTISE ON THE ONE THING THAT
ZELENSKYY SAYS HE WANTS RIGHT
NOW.
YOU MENTIONED ANYTHING ABOUT
AIRSPACE AND YOU GET
EVERYBODY'S ATTENTION BECAUSE
WE HAVE SOME OF THE BEST
FIGHTER PILOTS ON THE PLANET.
BUT WE CANNOT ENGAGE  PRO VOC
ACTIVELY.
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT AIR
SUPPORT WHERE WE COULD PLAY A
ROLE.
GO INTO DETAIL ON THAT.
>> WHAT I'M SAYING WE CAN
CONDUCT COVERT OPERATIONS TO
CONDUCT PINPOINT AIR DROPS AND
ALSO TO RESUPPLY AT REMOTE AIR
FIELDS THAT DON'T HAVE LIGHTS.
WE HAVE ALL THIS CAPABILITY.
CAN'T GET INTO THE DETAILS BUT
GENERALLY SPEAKING WE HAVE
CONDUCTED COVERT OPERATIONS
BEFORE FOR YEARS.
WE HAVE THE PEOPLE TO DO THAT.
WE HAVE AN INTELLIGENCE AGENCY
THAT GOES TO TITLE 50 TO DO
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
THE PRESIDENT HAS TO ISSUE A
FINDING AND THERE IS RISK
ASSOCIATED WITH IT.
I'M NOT SUGGESTING THERE IS NOT.
IT HAS TO BE LOOKED AT
CAREFULLY BUT IT CERTAINLY
SHOULD BE ON THE MENU OF THINGS
THAT WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT
PARTICULARLY IF WE ARE ALL IN
AND DEAD SERIOUS ABOUT GIVING
THE UKRAINIANS EVERYTHING THEY
NEED TO HELP.
>> Harris: WE BETTER BE.
>> THIS IS A PART OF THAT AND
PART OF THE STRATEGY.
>> Harris: LISTENING TO
ZELENSKYY WHO HAS ONE OF THE
BEST ABILITIES RIGHT NOW
CERTAINLY FAR OUTREACHING
VLADIMIR PUTIN WHO HAS BEEN AT
IT FOR YEARS AS A PRESIDENT OF
ANOTHER NATION, I GUESS YOU
COULD CALL HIM THAT.
HE IS A DICTATOR.
BUT ZELENSKYY OUT WEIGHS
PUTIN'S ABILITY TO COMMUNICATE.
IF YOU LISTEN TO HIM, HE IS
SAYING THAT'S THE KIND OF HELP
HE NEEDS, THAT AND THE
INTELLIGENCE.
EVERYBODY HAS TO BE ALL IN BUT
IF WE'RE PART OF THAT, GENERAL,
I KNOW FROM YOUR OWN HISTORY OF
LEADERSHIP, OUR MEN AND WOMEN
ARE MORE THAN READY TO DO THAT
COVERT WORK.
REAL QUICKLY WHAT'S THE RISK?
>> WELL, THE RISK IS DETECTION
AND THE FACT THAT WELL, IT
LOOKS LIKE WE COMMITTED AN ACT
OF WAR AGAINST THE RUSSIANS.
THAT'S THE RISK.
AND OUR NATIONAL SECURITY TEAM
WILL TAKE THE PRESIDENT THROUGH
THOSE RISKS AND OPTIONS.
MY CONCERN WITH THIS
ADMINISTRATION FROM THE OUTSET
HAS BEEN THEIR TIMIDITY AND THE
FACT THAT THEY -- THEY ARE
SOMEWHAT RISK AVERSE.
WHAT I'M CALLING FOR HERE IS A
LITTLE IMAGINATION AND SPINE.
AND I THINK WE CAN PROVIDE SOME
SIGNIFICANT HELP TO THE
UKRAINIANS AND MINIMIZE THE
RISK OF GOING THE WAR WITH
RUSSIA OVER IT.
>> Harris: I JUST WROTE THAT
DOWN.
WHAT A FOUR STAR GENERAL SAYS
YOU NEED IS SOME IMAGINATION
AND A LITTLE BIT OF SPINE.
YOU HAVE GIVEN US SOME THINGS
TO WORK WITH.
A PEP TALK AND FACTS AND
EXPERIENCE AND I'M GRATEFUL
EVERY TIME YOU ARE IN FOCUS,